hi i'm brad gaddis the author of
advanced google adwords the founder of
certified knowledge
and the ppc faculty chair for market
motive
in this module we're going to look at
the buying funnel and see how it applies
to search
first you may see this written as the
buying cycle the buying funnel the
decision making funnel the decision
making cycle so forth
it's all the same name sometimes it's
five steps sometimes it's three steps
it's okay if you see it in a different
format
consumers go through the same choices
regardless of how the charts are written
now we're going to go through the
decision making funnel to reinforce the
concept
that a consumer goes through these steps
and making a decision to buy a product
or use a service off the term buying
funnel is connected with e-commerce
it does not matter if your b2b or your
b2c your customers mentally go through
this process
now the first step is awareness
someone must be aware of your product
before they can buy or even want to
learn more
so the first step is introducing the
product or service to the individual
the second step is known as interest
when someone's aware of your product
then you need to make that user become
interested in your product
this is where introducing benefits such
as how your product or service will make
their life better
can help engage a consumer to wish to
learn more about your products
then we have the learn phase or learning
stage that comes next
so once interest has been generated it's
time for the consumer to learn more
about your products or service
this is the stage where you can begin to
introduce jargon terms and the
descriptions of your products
don't focus on features yet continue
showing them how the product will
improve their life
for b2b companies this is often where
webinar or white paper download
is a good conversion activity next we
have the shop or shopping stage
this is where consumers start comparing
different products and services
and features of those products
in this stage you want to showcase your
features and why your product is unique
or better from the other products and
services on the market
for b2b companies this is often where
you'll make your pitch to sell the
customer
final is the buy phase
once the user has settled into the exact
product and vendor then they finally buy
a product or sign a contract with a
service agency congrats you made a sale
however your work is not done yet you
now need to support the product and the
consumer
at this point in time you should start
focusing on the lifetime visitor value
of that customer
so let's look at how the buying cycle
applies to search
in this scenario we'll look at a
simplistic product someone might go
through when buying a large screen tv
so the first step
someone searches for hctv
they need to learn about the different
types of large screens such as plasma
leds lcds so forth the consumer does not
know the jargon yet
they're still learning about big screen
tvs
so once they learn about hc tvs we'll
assume the person settled into buying a
plasma tvs so look around the different
types of plasma tvs and their features
they'll compare the features between
plasma tv
models different brands to decide what
model they want to buy
finally consumer decides to buy the
samsung pn58b550
the searcher inputs a product number to
compare vendor prices
return policies warranty so forth then
once they decide which site to buy from
they purchase the product
in the case of buying an expensive
product
there might have been many more searches
conducted at each phase
for instance at the learn phase domain
also have searched for pixel burnout or
samsung plasma tv reviews
in the shopping phase you might have
searched for samsung plasma tv sony
plasma tv 60 inch plasma tv or product
part number extended warranties so forth
and the buying phase
the minute search for plasma tvs with
free shipping
where to buy this plasma tv
so what's important to note
is that there were no searches that took
place in the awareness or interest phase
of the buying cycle
awareness and interest are really
difficult to promote across the search
network
reaching customers and these two phases
of the decision making cycle is easier
on the display network
that's the network that's not searched
where you can put your ads on the new
york times wall street journal other
places it's still paid search
but the display network has a different
reach
so you might have some keywords that do
fit into the awareness interest cycles
it's common to find these are more
symptom and problem based types of words
and we'll get into that keyword type in
our next section we look at keywords
so in this example the consumer kept
conducting searches to advance
themselves through the buying cycle
that's not always the case
let's take a look at a different type of
buying cycle
so in this example we'll look at someone
who wants to buy a new book
as they like to read the latest and
greatest novels
the searcher starts by searching for
top book bestsellers
and the user sees an ad from amazon so
they go to amazon sites
the user learns that amazon has a
bestseller list they read through the
list
next they pick out some books that look
interesting
and they start reading reviews
reading reviews is the shopping phase
you're comparing what other people have
thought about the book
so once they find a book they like
sounds like it meets their interest
they buy it from the same place they saw
the best seller list
and read the book reviews amazon's case
in this instance
so in this example the user continued to
the decision making cycle while only
conducting a single search
so usually as a global statement
usually the buy cycle will have the
highest return on investment
however there's also lower search volume
than words higher in the funnel
it's called a funnel because people
leave it all the time causing less
individuals to progress to the next
stage
just because you've learned about a
product does not mean you will buy the
product
hence why each phase has less people in
it than the previous one
it's also important to note you cannot
jump someone ahead in the
decision-making funnel
for instance if someone is in the learn
phase and you sound to a buy now page
they'll often hit the back button
and look for their answer elsewhere
the user did a search because they want
the answer to a question if your page
does not answer the question
they're going to look elsewhere you must
let the user advance through each stage
now in this example if the amazon ad
went to a specific book page and the
user wants one of our top best sellers
these monitors hit the back button and
looked at a different bestseller list
when the query is informational such as
top best seller books
you need to answer the question before
the user will conduct a transaction
this does not mean the focus your page
can only be about the specific states
are in
the user is in the learns phase
the landing page answers the question
and then has a call to action for them
to take the next step
many users will progress to the next
stage
of the buying cycle on your website
that's why it's important to look at the
consumer behavior in this instance the
learn phase is a good keyword search and
has good roi from a revenue standpoint
just not an awareness standpoint
now this first two examples have been
focused on b2c queries
the same process does apply to b2b
companies as well
in this example we'll look at selling
b2b software let's say your business is
currently using a blackberry server to
sync emails and contacts across
corporate mobile phones
so the head of it
reads about this new microsoft operating
system and how it will have excellent
integration in the outlook it might
offer some additional collaboration
opportunities for the company
at this point in time he was already
aware of blackberry system but now he
learns about the new microsoft one
so now he's at the awareness phase for
the microsoft product
and next he sees a display ad from ibm
that touts the new mobile sync features
of lotus notes
the initial view of the ad places him in
the awareness cycle of lotus notes as
well
he clicks on the ad and reads a little
bit more about notice
so this point in time the it manager
feels he can lower total cost of the
company and offer additional services to
the company's employees if you were to
switch systems
so he conducts searches
and downloads a lot of white papers to
read about the various products
during this process he enters the
awareness interest on learn phases at
several other competing companies
so he picks his favorite three
google apps ibm lotus notes and
microsoft exchange
to contact so it can interview the
vendors and get in-person demos
he's now actively shopping and comparing
features
and total cost of ownership for the
company
finally
he picks a controversial choice google
apps the lower total cost of ownership
because he feels transition the company
to more cloud-based service
will help their collaborative efforts in
the future and sign the contract to
google now the user went through every
stage of the decision-making cycle
at several stages of his decision he
entered the decision-making cycles of
various companies and abandoned the
cycles at others
however if at the learn phase a company
did not offer a white paper for him to
read the technical specs on
implementation strategies of the
technology he would have abandoned that
company completely
in his decision-making process he wanted
to compare white papers so if one of the
actually searches early in this cycle
was by today
for a free implementation
he might have skipped the ad completely
as he was not going to implement this
big change that day the ad was too far
along the decision making cycle
compared to where he still was and that
learn phase
so that's why it's so important
to look through how your customers buy
from you
what are their stages
of awareness interest learn shop buy
they want to do phone interviews do they
do in-person demos they want webinar
items to even offer a white paper you
must ask these questions of yourself
based upon how your consumers make
decisions
so you can reach them appropriately
through paid search
now why is this so important well one
steps ad copywriting
so there's two components of ad copy
we're going to talk about real quickly
we'll go into more detail in later
modules on ads
one is a feature
a feature is just facts about a product
or service
so let's say on my computer it weighs
3.3 pounds
it has a 7.5 hour battery life
that's just a feature the facts
they're not very compelling a lot of
times
a benefit is what a consumer gets out of
the product
so
your computer weighs 3.3 pounds why does
that matter who cares
well a benefit would be get rid of back
and shoulder pain from carrying around a
heavy laptop bag it only weighs 3.3
pounds
a 7 of hour butter life does that matter
to me
well if you do a lot of cross-country
flights you can now be productive the
entire way
because your body won't die in you
so features are easy to make they're
just
bullet point lists of facts about a
product
to make a benefit just finish the
sentence
it weighs 4.5 pounds who cares
it weighs 3.3 pounds so you can get rid
of back and shoulder pain from carrying
a heavy laptop bag that's why it matters
just finish the sentence
but also we're talking the buying cycle
why is this important the buying cycle
because
depends where someone is in the buying
cycle
what you want to focus on
as someone's the awareness stage you
want to show benefits
here's how we make your life better
you want to peak their interest enough
so they move from the awareness stage to
the interest stage
the interest age you still want to show
more benefits
peak their interest enough so they
continue through the cycle to learning
about a product
at the learn stage you start to
transition
from benefits and features so why it's
important to them
and here's some of the stuff you should
know factually about the product
when someone's shopping and comparing
products it's all about features
however we spend money
we engage in services we buy products
based upon what something does for us
that's a benefit message
so understanding
where your keywords are in the buying
cycle
helps you write better ads
to reach the searcher based upon where
they are in that decision making funnel
goes for landing pages as well all
landing pages aren't equal
a home page has a whole lot of traffic
to it
but if someone gets to a page and the
first thing you have to do is search
again
browse products
that really didn't meet their interest
level
if someone were searching for
baby strollers
you would want to use a category page
they said i want to know what baby
strollers
that query is in the learn phase
put into a category phase
if someone search for an actual baby
stroller name
you want to put them on the product page
the furthest most logical point in the
buying cycle that matches their search
query
let's go back to the buying funnel for a
moment
the awareness phase
your page's goal is to peak interest
at the interest phase you want page
should show why they need this
at the learn phase this is where you see
how to articles white paper downloads
newsletter subscriptions learn more
about the product
now move to the next section shopping
which is often more category based pages
or form based landing pages if you're
lead generation company if someone's in
the buy stage of the cycle you want to
put in a page they can buy that product
right now or call your company whatever
it is that you make revenue
so by looking through
first how customers
progress through these stages for your
products
now look at your keywords how you're
reaching a customer
at each of these stages
now the keywords they choose in their
search
will tell you where they are in their
phase
buy a candle
well that's a shop that's a buy based
query
compare lcd versus led televisions
that's a shopping category
big screen tvs
that's a learn page
so someone tells you where they are via
their search query
that helps you create an ad copy
based upon the proper benefits and
features
it helps you choose a landing page based
upon
what's going to help them to convert
so thinking about the buying cycle is
really important in paid search because
you get to control
when someone sees your ad
the ad copy you use the landing page you
use
so a good exercise is to take a step
back before you create an account before
you choose keywords
think about how
people buy from you write them down
then refer back to that information in
future modules when we go through
keyword selection and ad copy writing
and landing page decisions
when you have the buying cycle in mind
you match the consumer intent
and when you match those correctly
that's when more conversions happen